[Music]
you're not hearing
anything about it most of the time but
our border is still completely out of
control
thousands of migrants coming over
unimpeded fox's bill milligan has been
covering this
undercover story he joins us now with
the very latest on hey bill
hey tucker good evening to you so we are
here in texas's rio grande valley this
is by far the busiest sector along the
u.s mexico border
the border agents down here will talk to
you themselves and tell you they're
frustrated they're overwhelmed they're
stretched thin
they need a lot of help and we got some
brand new video to show you it's pretty
remarkable
and it really highlights just what they
have to deal with day in
and day out down here take a look at
this drone video our fox drone team shot
yesterday morning right here in la jolla
it shows
dozens of migrants just making an open
run on the u.s border crossing in
illegally and trying to get away from
border patrol these are not people
turning themselves in like we've seen
often
these are people trying to get away
mostly adults mostly men you'll see two
of the men
are actually already handcuffed together
suggesting
they had already been in border patrol
custody and got away
you'll see one lone border agent in a
pickup truck desperately
trying to chase this crowd down but
they're running through open fields in
all different directions he is badly
outnumbered
that crowd continues running away some
of them run through what appears to be a
stream or a culvert
they keep going one border agent is
continuing trying to chase after them
one migrant kind of gets stuck in the
water or loses his shoe
the main group keeps running the border
patrol keeps going after them
you see some of them end up trying to
scale a fence scale a wall to get away
ultimately we did see border patrol
catch up with about
15 of that group but from what we saw it
appeared that
at least half of that group did end up
getting away and was able to escape in
the brush
we mentioned this happens like clockwork
almost every morning every day down here
take a look at this video we shot
this morning also here in la jolla we
witnessed another group of migrants
once again running away from border
patrol escaping into the brush
where they disappeared this time they
were spotted more quickly by border
patrol they were able to get a
helicopter over the area pretty quickly
able to pin some of those migrants down
eventually they were able to arrest two
of those migrants
brought them out to the trucks took them
away just the ongoing security con
security concerns tucker right here last
week they arrested an active ms-13 gang
member who had a warrant for his arrest
in houston
for sexual assault of a child we'll send
it back to you
bill malugen thanks for that report i
appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else